bonjour à tous et à toutes
dans le cadre de 115 digue consacré aux
municipales nous recevons ce matin
véronique panfilo diane bonjour vous
êtes la présidente de l'association silo
solidarité pour les initiatives le
rhinoise un mouvement citoyen et vous
êtes tête de liste d'agir pour le lourd
c'est bien ça tout à fait alors qu'est
ce qui a motivé votre candidature
alors eh bien évidemment permettez-moi
tout de même de me présenter je suivis
au licp en fils comme vous l'avez dit
mais je suis une wii noire
je suis né aux lorrains de parents louis
noah j'ai fait toute ma scolarité aux
lorrains je suis également directrice
administratif et financier dans une
entreprise de gestion et
d'investissement mais également un agent
de la ctm en disponibilité parce que je
viens du conseil général et j'ai piloté
l'agenda 21
pendant une bonne dizaine d'années donc
aujourd'hui présidente d'association à
partir de laquelle un mouvement
politique émerge aujourd'hui
alors évidemment vous me demandez
pourquoi je suis candidate j'ai d'abord
été sollicité par des lots et noah qui
m'ont demandé de me porter candidate
j'ai rencontré évidemment sur le terrain
de nombreuses personnes et j'ai accepté
cette mission qui qui les loonois
souhaite en tout cas ont voulu me
confier donc aujourd'hui ce qui me
motive c'est vouloir redonner la
confiance aux laurines war et le goût
d'entreprendre à travers un projet de
transition écologique économique et
sociale
alors avant de parler de votre projet
pourquoi les haut-rhinois ont perdu le
goût
le goût d'entreprendre écoutez je ne
sais pas monsieur libre ici vous
traversez le lorrain de temps en temps
mais vous vous rendez bien compte que
nous avons sur autres à travers ça en
tout cas la ville il ya quand même une
ombre une ombre parce que il y a de la
tristesse nous avons énormément de
logements d'habitat insalubre les routes
très souvent ils ce sont les habitants
en tout cas acquis qui nous font cette
remarque parce que voyez vous nous avons
organisé au mois d'octobre dernier une
assemblée citoyenne on allait justement
y pendre en parler alors si c'est vrai
vous avez organisé une assemblée
citoyenne afin de recueillir l'avis de
la population cas ce qui ressort donc
dossiers de ces premières rencontres
alors de ces premières rencontres il y a
beaucoup de questions sur notamment le
commerce sur la diversification des
commerces aux lorrains il y a également
une inquiétude au sein de la population
sur notamment la question alimentaire et
la restauration de notre agriculture
je n'ai jamais parlé avec des petits
planteurs également avec des
agriculteurs et la recherche la quête en
tout cas d'une alimentation saine a fait
l'objet d'un long débat dans un atelier
que nous avons eu à animer au mois
d'octobre dernier mais il y a également
d'autres d'autres points qui ont été
soulignés d'autres enjeux pour le
lorrain tels que notamment la question
de la sécurité
voyez-vous parce que nous avons des
lieux au lorrain où il ya un manque de
sécurité
c'est au visage plus manque de sécurité
alors alors je vais vous donner un
exemple très simple récemment nous avons
eu une réunion dans un quartier
notamment le quartier séguinaud où il y
a très récemment eu dès la construction
de logements sociaux
figurez-vous que j'étais bien étonné
mais en tout cas les personnes nous on
nous ont fait comprendre que il n'ya une
falaise derrière c'est ce lotissement et
des enfants vont jouer parce qu'il ya de
nouveaux habitants qui ne connaissent
pas les soirs du quartier qui ne
connaissent pas
les dangers qui peuvent justement
résulter de cet espace et ses enfants
vont jouer et il y à un risque donc il
faut sécuriser la falaise
il y a également le désenclavement de
cette de cette cité parce qu'il ya des
voitures qui roulent très vite donc ce
son si vous voulez ce sont des doléances
au quotidien mais ils ont également le
désir d'aller beaucoup plus loin nous
avons ressenti et c'est d'ailleurs
pourquoi notre projet s'intitule le
lorrain terre de réconciliation et de
progrès alors justement parlant du
projet un projet collectif de transition
sociale et écologique qu'est ce que tout
cela cache qu'est-ce qui est derrière
ces mais alors ça ne cachait rien ça
cache absolument absolument rien
aurez-vous quand on parle de
réconciliation
nous parlons de la réconciliation des
hommes avec la nature la réconciliation
des hommes entre eux et la
réconciliation du lorrain avec son
territoire avec l'ensemble de
l'agglomération dans laquelle il est le
leur et doit retrouver sa place dans le
nord aujourd'hui et c'est une
interrogation qui est posée par les
différentes personnes
quand on parle de transition économique
nous parlons justement d'économie
sociale circulaire et solidaire parce
que voyez vous vous avez des
agriculteurs vous avez des commerces sur
le territoire mais il n'y a pas cette
entente et il n'y a pas cette cohérence
dans le produit qui est proposé aux
habitants du lorrain est également du
nord puisque voyez-vous le lorrain c'est
tout de même une commune ou pour aller
au grand nord il faut passer par par le
lorrain donc le lauréat un rôle
important à jouer et également sur nos
trois bassins nous trois grandes
rivières il y a beaucoup à faire
madame véronique pas fait lousiane je
vous remercie